gérald est ce que le canada avait le
choix ou non de conclure cet accord avec
les pays du pacifique à ce qui pouvait
se permettre de juste laissé passer le
train
probablement pas mais en même temps faut
se rappeler que le canada parti n'a pas
participé à toutes les négociations
depuis 2005 le canada est arrivé dans
cette négociation là en 2012 parce que
pendant un bon moment ont jugé que ce
n'était qu'un accord régional les états
unis négocier avec différents pays du
pacifique pour se faire un contre
pouvoir à la chine mais avec le japon
avec douze pays comme ça avec onze pays
plus le canada le canada voyait
véritablement un intérêt de saint céré
là dedans pourquoi parce que le canada
aura accès à partir de maintenant au
japon
l'histoire de cet accord pour le canada
c'est l'accès à la troisième économie
mondiale le japon le canada ne pouvait
pas rater cette chance d'accéder à ce
marché là le canada est un pays de
taille moyenne qui a une influence
moyenne 80% de ses exportations sont
avec des pays avec qui le canada a
conclu des accords de libre-échange donc
les états unis le mexique le pérou le
chili aujourd'hui à japon l'ensemble des
pays mais surtout le japon et est ce
qu'on peut se conclure ce genre d'accord
sans qu'il y ait des victimes des
perdants des victimes je vais employer
un langage militaire des victimes
collatérales vous savez on est dans ce
qu'on appelle la destruction créatrice
en économie c'est à dire que le libre et
charge ces on développe l'économie on
innove on crée des choses en avance mais
il ya des rejetés il y à des exclus ça
c'est le libre échange et les exclus ou
en tout cas ceux qui sont touchés
affectés aujourd'hui ce secteur de
l'automobile etc la gestion de l'eau les
puissants gagnent généralement les
secteurs les plus puissantes les
industries les entreprises les plus
puissantes gagne le pari du canada
aujourd'hui c'est de se dire qu'on
n'avait pas le choix on est mieux d'être
là que de ne pas être là le bilan net
selon gouvernement sera positif merci
beaucoup gérald et nous sommes en
campagne électorale les chefs de partis
ont réagi en exprimant certains leur
inquiétude aujourd'hui on les écoute